now which brings me to one thing that
everyone wants to know because this is
the story that everyone wants to hear um
stuart where's an eye patch we've seen
it in the in the uh
in the mug shots
and in the tunnel videos like we said
earlier the spider whole
uh tactical whole he did not have an eye
patch so there is a story going around
that he shot himself in the eye um i
don't know how that is what it is do you
guys know the story and can you tell us
the story of how stuart seemed to have
an eye patch okay this is three stories
there is the event
okay and the facts that happened
and there's also this story he told
there's
which is mostly lie
there's
also
what i believe actually happened and it
took me 20 years to piece it together
and then
there's the second event which is why he
stopped wearing a prosthetic eye
um i guess i'll start with him shooting
himself in the face
okay yeah sure
start there start there please
so um he and i were dating um i was 18.
this is 1991.
um we've been dating for a few months
and already even though i had grown up
you know mormon household you know man
is in charge of everything i still
thought
i don't know this guy's kind of
controlling you know he's not that nice
and i think i think i might be out of
here you know and i get this call
that there's been an accident
and he has shot himself in the eye and i
didn't know what the story was and then
the story that he gave was that his
mother had had a derringer in a drawer
um
derringers for people that don't know
have no internal safeties they're like a
gun out of the old west that's the
technology of them
if you drop a glock it's not going to
fire the only handguns that fire when
you drop them are you know overly
tricked out colts and you know 45
guys just do ridiculous things or the
very cheap ones they're very cheap ones
that's a very cheap one and um
so he dropped he he was giving it to a
friend of his the dairy needed correct
the daryn jones is bringing the darren
from his mother's house
to the friend because he said he needed
a gun he couldn't buy a gun because he
was a felon he was uh
his friend was a convicted um crack
dealer and had done time for that this
is a friend from high school
and he said he was just bringing it to
him he's just bringing it to him
because he he keeps getting in fight
with fights with gang members and now
they're targeting him and needs
protection and for people who don't know
a derringer it's going to be a very
small concealable pistol
it's why it's so simple does it hold two
shots maybe basically it's a it's a
sleeve gun in some models
it's the one you see in the movies where
when they're playing the poker great
thing yeah yeah
it comes out and bang bang bang right
right so that is what that was and so he
said they stopped
and um people familiar with las vegas
this is basically downtown las vegas i
believe it was an on industrial street
every town's got an industrial street
they look alike right
industrial and
mlk drivers it's the same kind of
neighborhood it's it's
it's closed down mechanic shops and
there's no reason for them to have been
there this guy lived in a downtown las
vegas they were traveling they stopped
to get a drink there's no air
conditioning in his car it's like 110
degrees you drop the gun he heard
something which this makes no sense
timing wise by the way he said he heard
it drop and then he looked down and then
when it landed right this already it's a
lie and it shot him in the eye
this is
so that's the story
it shot him in the eye
the exactly the story that he tells yeah
so and it's a 22 so it's bouncy he was
with that front that part's true and it
rattled around his eye socket and it
came out it was just sitting
under the skin here and they removed it
the bullet was the bullet was yesterday
wow why they removed the the bullet his
friend drove him to the hospital he's
kind of a funny guy and he's a crack
dealer he was nicer guys than stewardess
crack crack viewers can have sense of
he said he drove stuart's car they ran
into the emergency room the place was
full of cops and he threw his hands up
and said hey hey give me all the tickets
you want about five minutes and then
they immediately said 68 camaro oh yeah
we heard we had calls and so that was
the story
um
ah i have another version well you know
you know the version that's going around
that that people are assuming is that he
was giving lessons on firearms right and
then somehow he was an instructor or
something and then he had been a
firearms instructor later but at that
time that has nothing to do with the
gunshot in the this is when he was 25
years old um people are assuming because
it's it's funny to say he was teaching
right
right
long before he ever taught firearms he
did work at a gun store one day a week
just so he could shoot for free and get
discount ammo so he'd been wearing a
prosthetic eye for yesterday
the atlantic i think did a pretty big
story on him and they said he shot his
in 93 and that was probably my fault
because i provided all the background
info on that story but i talked fast i
changed subjects really fast and i think
you know i went over there but you're
you're saying it was 1991
okay it's kind of what you're but the
atlantic story reported 93 but you're
thinking anyone yeah and it's something
i did and the thing that rings false for
me especially
knowing him
never really admits to anything without
downplaying it or building a cover story
with half truths and the part that he's
admitting to
point blank at the beginning of talking
about how he shot his eye out
is he was illegally transferring an
unregistered firearm to a felon yes
right that he knew what he knew he was
yeah
yeah and they're they're in a shady part
of town too i mean this isn't like right
right you know this isn't like at the
olive garden this is in you know a
rundown part of
las vegas
so over the years
you're laughing
at the olive garden
over the years he told this story
and he always told it from beginning to
end like a robot
the facts never change you know when
something gets true
sometimes you can go down a different
road of the story you can give more
information like oh what were you where
were you why were you guys going that
way you know and you can add things to
it just by virtue of it's not just five
facts it's a full afternoon
was he unwilling to like so typically
when you tell a story people want to you
know probe and ask questions to kind of
find out more details like you know what
the hell that's crazy so it was he the
person that if you were to ever ask
questions he would just like stick to
he's like yes let me let me just finish
the story and then we continue down the
robotic kind of way that you stated and
it's not like stewart it's not how he
acts and like dakota said he's admitting
he's admitting a crime in the opening
line of it
right right yeah or believing anyone
else he shot himself in the face he
didn't blame anyone else for it so i
already uncharacteristic that's
i mean if you're going to make up a
story try not to say that you're
committing a crime in the made-up story
right so
now his friend was a convicted crack
dealer
um continued to deal crack and
um and pimp
for years after that
um this is somebody he knew from high
school
um later on i heard him mention multiple
times that his friend henry had asked
him to help run security for people who
owed him money that means drug deal
right
you're a drug dealer people owe you
money you mean in front of the olive
garden
right he's like you need to be muscle
run the door right right right and so
he mentioned that multiple times over
the years he also had a tendency when
he's scared
to hide weapons in the palm of his hand
to try to palm a weapon like this right
right which is the perfect gun for a
dinner or like a derrick right
absolutely and it's unregistered like
the cars it was unregistered that's a
continuing pattern there yeah
it'd been traded to his mother maybe 10
years prior by an old man who was dead
he's changed owners
there's no connection to stewart in this
gun so if he was going to run security
to drug deal this is the firearm he
would use if his friend said hey i need
to go collect some money
especially especially if you're at close
range because this is a 22. it's a
close-range weapon
so i think he was running security for
his friend for a crack deal
i think he dropped the gun and shot
himself in the face and like how awkward
and i think
i just think only stewart could you know
run security for a drug deal in downtown
las vegas and still not look cool
so tell us about the eye patch how did i
mean how did we go from
stuart with a with a prosthetic eye all
these years to an eye patch is there a
story behind that you said this quick
version is um the eye patch is because
he quit cleaning and showering and he
quit taking cleaning his um prosthetic
eye he just left it in like it's like a
contact lens he left it in for like two
years instead of taking it out every
night and his eye socket got so infected
that the eye socket ruptured
and pushed out the prosthetic had to be
moved removed by the specialist and then
the implant
that took the shape of where his eyeball
used to be pushed out and he was no
longer able to wear a prosthetic
his eye socket is now swollen out of
proportion and can no longer support a
prosthetic eye and he never went in for
the surgery to correct that and redo an
implant i see so he's forced to wear the
eyes this is like wearing a contact lens
and just going you know what i'm just
going to leave this in
what could go wrong
it's totally fine
i guess the humorous part about the
eyepatch to me
is that
he was he was he was
they got him in texas um and there's
another guy from texas with the eye
patch dan crenshaw yeah yeah
with the eye patch and just i just i'm
like this is so hilarious how in the
hell did this happen yeah i think that
crenshaw still stole stewart's look i
don't think he used to wear the eye
patch no he didn't no he didn't he
actually he actually said i think i
think he's done a couple interviews
where he's like the the actual
prosthetic eye doesn't look as tough as
the eye patch so he likes to wear that
you know what looks even tougher when
dan crenshaw makes an ad where he jumps
out of an airplane yeah and has to save
georgia yeah right right right right
that's really tough well you know the
other ones down in a wing suit to punch
through a black dude's windshield
because butler told him to
oh yeah
yeah he wants to be iron man so badly
right right well i i always i always in
my content when i'm talking about dan
crenshaw i say get a [ __ ] glass eye
would you please because because he he
literally he has one he's talked about
wearing it he just doesn't he chooses
yeah he can at least be the guy from
last action hero you know you get like
just anything right
and the other quick thing about the eye
thing is it you know at 18 if i had been
even 25 years old and this had happened
i just thought well this is unfortunate
that i was about to break up with this
guy
you know
and now he's injured and now my family
is his family's calling mike i'm all
involved in the whole family in the
drama and they're giving my family
updates
so it just completely drew me in and at
the time at 18 it was or 19 by the time
it happened and
you know i just thought well i'm stuck
now and it really
it caused me to be i i never would have
i would have so that's that's why we're
kind of here today yeah because he was
in front of the olive garden
possibly
maybe not doing a drug deal
drop the drop the weapon he was supposed
to use protection and shot himself right
in the eye um
if only there'd been an actual olive
garden well you know yeah
hey hey you know we're just snowballing
here we don't know how far there was an
olive garden away i mean you can never
tell you know it is big
after the drug deal they went to the
olympics right it's possible once they
got patched up he went through all right
i mean we're making
don't forget about the hooker part
that's applebee's oh no no
so there's a hooker story from
well all i know is the
henry was also a pimp so i believe
hooker's preferred oh okay okay so there
might have been hookers involved in this
deal okay